[Music]
this is a very very simple story um
two men in austin texas were arrested
for beating and nearly killing a food
vendor over his hot dog price what 14
dollars
guess what the price was was this that a
[ __ ] dodgers game six bucks austin
austin texas like little hot dog uh
carts i believe was it a mexican dude
with the bacon wrap hot dog and a no
palace cactus it hurts me to like yeah
we got that in austin too they always
pick on those maybe it's like an obscure
price where it's like uh it's like i'll
give you this hot dog you let me make
out your mom i wish it was something
yeah that sounds like a bargain
in no way was just beating warranted the
the hot dog price was six bucks oh come
on what did it used to be two see okay
a street dog is like five bucks because
inflation is tethered to hot dog prices
what price warrants a [ __ ] ass
beating like they never see nothing
twenty dollars that's the whole point of
market price it's you could go um i
don't want it but aren't they being
capo's pieces of [ __ ] though twenty
dollars
you try to sell me a hot dog for twenty
dollars i'm [ __ ] you beating ass how
much is a hot dog at dodger stadium oh
that's a lot maybe 12 bucks
yeah it's like 15 16 but the the the
wiener is longer than the bun yeah
that's true that's very hard but i still
think hands down costco has the best oh
is this your water or mine you got
possessed by sam's club dude
costco
costco said not spawn
how did that phlegm come up
street dogs are the best though i'm a
big fan of street i love the la street
dogs the 16-inch dogs at dodger stadium
are 21 oh what man i'm [ __ ] up
everybody at the dodgers stadium
no you could [ __ ] go to chinese
restaurant buy a lobster for that price
yeah you can some lobster noodles 21
dollars and the one that's still
swimming too and their hot dogs are not
even like the good [ __ ] long ones
dude it's like the little ones
[ __ ] oscar meyer ballpark ones so
these two guys they nearly killed the
dude over the six dollar price i mean
i'm sure they were like six dollars and
then the guy was like yeah go [ __ ] you i
don't know maybe you didn't say that
that's new york man that's what they
said the price was hey if you don't want
a hot dog go [ __ ] yourself then what
what's the austin texas version well if
it's a mexican dude he'd be like i'm
sorry sir inflation
inflation
yeah is a 21 year old 19 year old guy uh
they beat the dude up and they the hot
dog vendor was found covered in blood
outside a bar
a cop was there took him to the hospital
he had life-threatening injuries
including a gash in his head requiring
staples a lacerated liver
and widespread widespread pain all over
his body yeah i beat him up real good
huh did we see the hot dog do we know it
was a hot dog or not he put two pieces
of bread around the hot dog because then
i'd probably kick his ass too two pieces
of like wheat bread yeah what you mean
like hey some people like that don't
they put two pieces of bread around is
weiner yeah people in hospitals like
that because that's that's where they go
that's the australian way they do it
really yeah they should all get beat up
it's like it's like a famous thing
outside of this uh hardware store called
bunnings it's like a
some kind of like sausage sizzle they
call it you go outside everybody does it
apparently it's just two slices of white
bread and a freaking frank in the middle
that is so
uncomfortable and they do it all the
time i went to a car show out there like
a little car meet someone was doing it
there they sold it for like a buck is
that like a piggy and a blanket but more
like a pig and a giant blanket like what
is that that just sounds like boy scouts
do they admit that do they admit they
like it out loud or is it like they love
it oh really sasha's sizzle yeah it's
like it's like a pastime or maybe it's a
a bogan thing i don't know better be
like hawaiian british you had uncle uh
what's his name yesterday
roger uncle roger off camera he's
talking about how much he loves panda
he's like don't tell anybody but i love
panda express well maybe that's that uh
guilty pleasures you know it's like
stuff that's uh it's like low classy
yeah have you um guys uh
ever had a hot dog where the the hot dog
they [ __ ] put a knife through it and
they kind of split it and then
yeah and then they sizzle both sides so
it's extra crispy
and then so you know like a hot dog bun
it's like split like that right so the
hot dog is like a hot dog bun you can
put a ketchup and mustard in the middle
see i first explored a [ __ ] bowling
alley their diner in the bowling alley
they busted that out as a kid and i was
like mind blown and i was like damn this
is [ __ ] crazy bring the chef out i
need to thank him and my mom was like
man my son is so creative because she
thought that i invented that [ __ ] have
you ever got a hot dog
get a chopstick stick it through the
middle pull out the chopstick and i have
a hot dog straw nah why would i do that
but what i've done do is i put a i put a
chopstick through i turn on the stove
and i started roasting hot dogs like
that and now i got my ass beat that's
the real thing you did made a hot dog
straw yeah cause it makes whatever you
drink tastes funny hot
if that's what you want if you want to
make whatever you're drinking tastes
funny get a hot dog straw a mad tv way
of dining it's like i know what you guys
are thinking we have a problem like how
do i get hot dog flavored water quickly
hot dog strong
was it cooked was it raw i like want to
know the details were you drinking milk
no i'm pretty sure it was cooked do you
guys do the [ __ ] slices on the side
like this when you do the hot dog oh the
little diagonals i tried diagonal ones
yeah yeah wait i still want to know
what's the optimum thing to drink with a
hot dog straw i don't know elementary
school you're just doing experiments
hey ketchup you drink ketchup with a hot
dog straw bart was a menace as a child
your perspective on how to like
manipulate anything it's really you ever
take a hot dog and put your boner in it
that's disgusting
that's where he draws the line dude okay
keep it over there that's such a bart
thing
what i'd probably prefer to do is maybe
take some l.a looks hair gel put in a
ziplock bag put a microwave for me i
don't know good 10 15 seconds and then
put that on the wiener
i never did that before but it sounds
like i feel good what does microwaves do
it looks that's
nice and squishy and warm and cozy
that's actually something's making me
legitimately curious oh
that's uh
that's what stevie weeby told us to do
he did yeah
not l.a looks but you know but a similar
theory like a similar type of yeah yeah
so that's yours but with l.a looks huh i
just made it out cause i just what's the
most you would pay for a hot dog
nine dollars nine is your math well i
think i paid 12 before like a nice
little bra you know yeah i bet you i'd
pay 24 dollars when i go to the dodger
stadium i have to pay tax yeah i don't
want a hot dog because you're to eat a
hot dog there yeah
what's your price dog what's your top
price that's what i named my uh my dog
daughter dog depends what kind of hot
dog because i went to that uh dog house
oh okay and they got some fancy hot dogs
is pretty good they make like you know
the hawaiian
buns yeah they got all kinds of ones
they got chili dogs that like have like
texas toast on it and all that hawaiian
buns are the best yeah do you guys have
that in paradise oh you mean pasadena
yes we do
i feel like i spent like 13 bucks on
that but it felt like worth it how's the
line was it like pinks yeah oh no
nowhere near is pink's overrated yes oh
but that one time i was stoned exactly
oh remember that one that's because
stoned is underrated
that's different for a line down the
block it's not good enough we got like
little hot dog bites and every burst of
a bite it felt like
it was like heaven in the mouth dude
that was the best hot dog i ever had was
well we were in vegas that one time high
and eating pink coming from someone
who's never been high when you're high
does does food taste you've never been
high kinda yeah it kind of does so have
you ever been high have you ever been
high had the munchies ate something and
had a negative review of the food never
wow
if you eat [ __ ] it's still going to be
[ __ ] it's not it it heightens what you
like that's a good it heightens that's
why it's called the highest and it makes
your choices better that's true because
i never ate [ __ ] like bad food when i
was high like what do you think about
hot pockets they're okay yeah they're
good they're high and you eat hot
pockets and you're hungry right but the
hand and cheese are good already you're
just trying to eat that any time it's a
religious experience yeah
i just can't stop eating when i'm high
or like taking flamin hot cheetos and
dip it in philadelphia cream cheese when
you're high that sounds fun
diarrhea my boy but that sounds good i
feel like fast food was invented to uh
have when you're drunk or high yeah like
the chef was probably like [ __ ] high
as [ __ ] and then like developing all
these things for taco bell [ __ ] like who
thinks of five dollars
midnight [ __ ] snack boxes they
literally call it the munchie box yeah
like jack in the box i think when you're
high it's like a sexual eating
experience it is you know when you get
those quite sexual tacos from jack in
the box that no one gets but it's really
good and there's oil like
like just dripping out better before
like if you're sober you're gonna do the
dumpster two for a dollar ones the soy
ones yeah i love it if you're sober you
can do the dumb thing and just eat it
straight if you're high you're going to
stick your lip out like this
and then rub it
remove the oil because you want a
foreplay first i don't know if you're
selling it right now
drag it across your mouth
you get high huh we got to get bar high
dude market's
wow would you trust a like a i don't
know like one of those uh food rating
review things but the person's high
every time they eat it i trust it more
you trust me i might trust it more yeah
yeah because those guys are pretty chill
and they don't have an agenda if you're
high you don't have a [ __ ] agenda
that's true
that's very true you're all about the
experience and it's super honest you
know like i'm trying to get more clicks
you're like hey man the world is [ __ ]
awesome we need to love each other more
yeah
you guys need to try these [ __ ]
tacos their cheeseburgers underrated
that'd be a pretty cool thing if it
didn't exist already like a michelin
star reviewer that's just constantly
high it exists oh it does i don't know
i'm sure somebody's already there i'm
sure there's a blog out there we just
have to search it up and we can find it
so what does it take for someone high to
not like what they're eating when the
food is not good
like i said it heightens whatever it is
how bad the food is oh they had a bad
high that could happen but their choices
aren't going to be good like they're not
going to be high and see orange with
like mold on and go um
yeah that's true that's very true
they're going to already go in the
section where it's like they would in a
dare commercial i think sometimes you'll
eat like say you're you're faded and
you're like building something up like
oh i want to eat this and you go get it
and it's underwhelming and you're like
uh you'll be let down but you'll still
enjoy it for the most part right you
know but it's not like that bad just get
over it just eat it you know it's not a
big deal
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you